okay if that's the case then then uh
close your eyes boys
i gotta i got the perfect one if we're
talking meme games okay uh i got the the
perfect one right here right and uh open
your eyes
i saw somebody
why did you buy this i got the i got the
full box set
[ __ ] sake
i couldn't not buy this this is
absolutely amazing oh no you didn't gone
wait did you buy the same
thing oh
no
all right
joey joey what did you buy exactly
i bought
wait
uh oh
oh i bought the buildable action figure
uh among us five to collect why they're
five
all right so uh one of my one of my
challenges was of course to get a
plushie yeah and uh i had a plenty of
options to find a lot of character
plushies um sorry and then like
for some reason this is like what was
that
and then uh hidden right in the corner
joey and then right in the corner
what's up
i'm augustus
yeah yeah you both lose a point yay what
the [ __ ]
what about you know what worth it for
the among us you know you know although
you know though i didn't want to stop
there because uh the plushie well you
got more among us the plushie needed a
friend okay the plushie
okay look like i know the challenge was
just to buy one character plushie yeah
but i felt like you know you could you
can't play among us with just one just
one person okay okay the character needs
a friend okay
we're selling our own smash bros right
here yeah right well among us in smash
when
that's practical
yeah i couldn't not get this yeah this
is too perfect what is this so these are
like buildable i guess like like lucky
boxes for a mogus character
can we get the boxes off the table
luckily none of these are the red the
red among yes
so does it count is it the same
character i don't know does it count
because none of them are red well let's
open them up and find out who is uh no
yeah
from the same series none of these are
red though
oh yeah he's from the same series yeah
but you've bought how many series from
jojo yeah yeah only one set of
duplicates
yeah but that that was only one set
right because he was dear so so you so
if i'm counting this is one yeah yeah so
you guys you've got the humongous guy
that's literally a character no no no i
got i got the red among them because
they're not they're not different though
there's the white
one there's the purple the green the
black the white and the red glow in the
dark they're all the same characters
look like look look they're just
different costumes it's the same
character when you're voting for someone
to get off right well dude it's the same
it's a different costume it's the same
character yeah we've already established
we both lose a point and i get a point
because it's ava
no no no no no no we've established that
we both don't lose a point yeah
i don't even know listen yeah yeah
no
he has not bought a red among us
character you can see there you can see
on the [ __ ] box they are the same
character when you vote someone after
you go the among us character
no you say reddish sass connor you don't
go
among us
you got reddit
you go [ __ ] purple as such you go
green slice you know you don't say among
us
what's their name it's red well it's a
crewmate it's red he's a crew it's a red
crewmate it's a fred crewmate yeah and
that's a crew mate it's a red crewmate
they're both the same guys
by that logic joey's probably bought
like 15 duplicates here no because i'm
counting this is one because it came in
one box
well if you open them all up how many
characters are there
five yeah i'm sorry you have five
duplicates no because this is one all
right well you can either take the five
minus points or you can take the one
minus points here that it does
it does not work like that it does not
work like no no no no no no no no no no
no no no not even trying to argue this i
am going to argue this till the day i
die if there was a red among us
character i will happily take the l yeah
yeah i agree if there was a red among
his character i'd be like joey yeah we
got the same
character because i literally i
literally tried like i literally like
predicted maybe one of these character
maybe one of these guys will buy an
among us character right so i was like
so i was like uh which i i actually had
to pick one that i thought the guys
wouldn't actually buy so i picked red
yeah and luckily there's no reason well
it sucks that you both got the crew made
so it doesn't matter you both lost the
point in the end that's a red crewmate
there isn't a right one point off of
them both
audience what do you think audience what
you're most definitely going to say
put this
put this under the contention
isn't this the stupidest [ __ ] your honor
your honor i object you're object you
can't you will look like clowns on the
video if you're actually trying to argue
this emergency meeting
emergency meeting
genuinely can't believe this is what
you're trying to argue for
you both lose one point oh my god
there's no doubt about it all right i
actually bought a b stars figure because
i wanted to take it away from connor
just in case i bought
around and i'm just like well i've got
all my points let's try let's try to
[ __ ] connor over um so you know i didn't
matter in the end anyway yeah it didn't
matter in the hell yeah that's it's such
a nice figure as well it is
did you even watch peace stars this year
though uh yeah season two i did okay
yeah so yes that's did you take one
point off of them actually uh it's under
contention
we're having points on the contention
this year no what the [ __ ] take it off
for them no no that's not it's under
contention this is not under under what
the court of the clowns what the [ __ ]
you know the court of the law
the court among us the court of among us
the court of the sus
i'm sorry i'm sorry but if we're going
far by among us laws then the majority
wins right it's by majority votes yeah
so therefore therefore you would have
been voted out if you're both in
agreement you can't just both keep
making up rules and then say we have the
majority we're not making overall that's
literally what you just did we did an
emergency meeting we voted and we voted
that your opinion was voted off because
you're in the same game the same figure
and the same characters so they vote the
same character are you colorblind the
same character
there is not none of these look like
this character they literally look the
exact same thing none of these they're
all
how can like six of them go around at
the same time they're all wearing
different costumes gone
because why because they're all the same
character because they're different
characters jonah no they're wearing what
do you say are you telling me they're
all clones or yes they are lit that is
literally the point of the thing is that
you can change color because there is no
distinction between them because they
are the same character
what if this guy's name is gary and this
guy's name is greg it's not
well how do we know have you have you
looked into among us at all yes they
don't have any names they're all the
same character
so every fact so all among us characters
are just clones of each other yes
i like to hear your opinions among us
fans uh anyone who's uh
knows anything about among us law i
think can back us up that uh these are
all different characters
we're literally can we call up
the developer we're literally never
gonna find out who's won